i hope they were real with each other
and there was like a genuine human
connection right that
i that seemed like johnson wasn't a
genuine guy
well i need to i need to read those
thousands of pages
i've been way too focused on hitler i
was gonna say one of my goals in coming
to this is i was like i gotta get lex
into two things because i know he'll
love it
i know he'll love lbj if he has to take
the time to read the books
100 he's the most of all the presidents
i didn't say you'll love him but you'll
love the books about him
because the books are a story of america
the story of politics the story of power
this is the guy who wrote the power
broker these books are up there with
decline and fall follow the roman empire
by edward gibbon in terms of
how power works study of power exactly
that's no
that's why carol wrote the books and
that's why the books are not really
about
lbj they're about power in washington
and about the consolidation of power
post new deal
the consolidation then or the using the
levers of power like johnson knew
in order to change the house of
representatives
the senate of the united states and
ultimately the presidency of the united
states which ended in failure and
disaster with vietnam
don't get me wrong but he's overlooked
for so many of the incredible things
that he did with civil rights nobody
else could have done it no
no one else could have gotten it done
you